je reçois maintenant claude rich pour sa
composition dans le derrière le deuxième
long métrage de valérie lemercier une
comédie filmant avec délice les moeurs
du milieu homo et dans laquelle claude
enrich d'endiguer nous est gay bonsoir
alors l'histoire c'est l'histoire de
frédéric eu un kit une flic et valérie
lemercier qui est né dans un haras d'une
saillie sans lendemain dans rêva les
étiez les talents qui cherche son père
qu'il n'a pas connu à l'heure trouvé la
mort à la france à la mort de sa mère
elle va à paris et elle vous trouve ou
alors là c'est le choc
elle vous trouve en ménage donc de son
père et en ménage avec dieudonné comme
le couple du siècle qui est proctologue
elle se travestir en garçon alors vous
parlez nous de votre personnage parce
que c'est quand même on vous a vu dans
beaucoup de films mais là c'est
grandiose
je suis conservateur d'un grand musée
parisien
je vis avec dieudonné je suis un homme
un peu qui se prend un petit peu au
sérieux qui est un petit peu on un peu
ces espèces wehrling porte une écharpe
rouge tout le long du film
enfin c'est un personnage très snob
fresno la rive gauche caviar russe
caviar un peu pierre bergé enfin je vous
avais pas je demande pas de me dire que
c'est lui dont il s'agit mais tout c'est
un personnage qui dont on voit quelques
fois dans les ministères quelques jeux
comme ça c'est sa lettre et rue de
valois
voilà voilà c'est ça alors ce que dit le
mercier c'est qu'en fait ces nouveaux
pouvoirs c'est dire qu'en fait le
pouvoir contrairement à ce qu'on pense
n'appartient plus aux costumes vide avec
des attaches et 15 mai à ces gens là
quoi le pouvoir la culture le pouvoir
des médias c'est un personnage important
qui vit avec un proctologue et qui
découvrant une fille qui lui arrive et
puis un fils un fils parce qu'il lui
arrive il est très surpris les
un peu mécontent parce que c'est de ce
fils a des allures un petit peu quand
même vite à ces snobs servent au début
quand elle est en filles s'intéressent
pas elle mais dès qu'elle s'habille en
garçons ils la remarque évidemment aux
est d'ailleurs l'idée de lemercier au
départ c'était d'annoncer sa son père au
moment de consommer alors c'était un peu
too much et donc elle a décidé de
l'annoncer dès le départ notre scénario
alors quand on vous a vu dans conan
capitaine conan quand on vous avez dans
le crabe tambour ou en compte de saint
gilles dans le bel été 14 de chalonge
c'est vrai que ça fait un choc mais
c'est vachement bien matin le couple
c'est amusant pour un acteur de jouer
tout quoi je veux dire et le fait qu' il
aime un homme au lieu des mets une femme
c'est toujours de l'amour oui oui non
mais c'est pas si c'est pas crapoteux
c'est très drôle c'était très très bien
joué
dieudonné formidable parce qu'il a cette
espèce de côté très sérieux qui l'a
parfois comme ça quand vous c'est la
première fois vous faites le rôle d'un
de nos maux à l'écran non ben oui
c'était amusant alors au début au
premier rendez vous quand vous en a
parlé vous ai dit oui en imaginant un
peu le personnage après vous ai lu le
scénario vous avez dit non et qu'est ce
qui vous a poussé à redire oui mais
c'est c'est d'avoir parlé avec valérie
quand je lui ai dit que j'hésitais à
cause parce que la première fois voilà
elle m'a téléphoné je laime beaucoup
alors si vous êtes surtout l'acteur
préféré de sa mère alors elle m'a donné
rendez vous elle m'a expliqué le
personnage ne ça m'amuse énormément et
elle m'a dit voilà je vous envoie le
scénario quand j'ai vu le scénario ça
correspondait pas tout à fait avec ce
qu'elle m'avait expliqué alors j'ai été
obligé de relire deux fois trois fois
et puis je lui ai dit que j'hésite elle
m'a dit mais réfléchissez comme vous et
quelques jours après j'ai dit oui c'est
bien fait le tournage c'est pas évident
au début là c'est un peu les jours de
tournage la dire que je pense que
valérie et l'actrice que nous
connaissons mais c'est aussi un auteur
13 qui a vraiment qui a du caractère et
qui
quand elle a eu peur que je veuille
peut-être infléchir dans manon mon sens
n'a pas voulu dieudonné a voulu aussi un
petit peu chaque acteur mais quand il
commence il essaie de masquer prendre
ses marques quoi je vais vous aider vous
aidiez à votre fameux rentrant le 1er
juin j'ai l'impression d'être un
débutant ce virtuel vous a quand même
serré vais commencer à travailler dans
son pays avait à la fin d'un d'une
phrase oui pfff
alors je faisais plus tu non on a fait
trente deux prises
alors je ne savais plus et à la fin
bombe
elle sait ce qu'elle veut c'est ce
qu'elle le résultat est bien alors on va
regarder un extrait donc ça s'appelle le
derrière de valérie lemercier avec
claude rich et puis tout ce que j'ai
cités magnéto alors quoi je vais
attendre mon tour avec ma serviette sous
le bras comme au camping
parce qu'il doit lui en falloir du temps
pour savonner un gourdin pas vrai
qu'après je suis quand même mon fils
c'est vrai pardon et c'est vrai que tu
t'en es très bien d'occuper à bientôt tu
veux le voir à son petit spectacle de
fin d'année avec mon petit caméscope non
l' écoute je sais pas très bien où tu
veux en venir
excuse moi mais moi je préfère être du
côté de la générosité
c'est un choix que j'ai fait et qui me
semble naturel surtout quand on la
chance comme nous d'avoir beaucoup reçu
c'est certain qu'il est plus simple de
ne pas aimer l'autre mais ce genre de
comportement de rejet cette
discrimination sans appel comme ça ça me
rappelle les choses pas jolies jolies
qui se sont passés il n'y a pas si
longtemps que ça
je crois qu'il est temps que je te
prenant rendez vous avec mon copain
bercot qui cessa bercot mais le
gérontologue donc le derrière ce
magnifique avec donc claude rich
dieudonné va laver lemercier plein d'eau
alors cloud est ce qu'on peut dire votre
âge vous dit pas écouté non mais c'est
arrivé qu'on le dise mais je préfère ne
pas le dire parce que je suis pas très
vieux mais je suis pour moi je suis
quand même pas heureusement
bon je ne dirais pas dans quelle case de
13 enfants oui c'est enfin parce que
alors je vous dis heureusement sinon
mais il ya cinq minutes j'avais les
cheveux jusque là oui alors je vais dire
d'une vieille dame mais maintenant qu'on
m'a coupé les cheveux
j'ai l'air d'un vieux monsieur vous avez
vous avez vous avez toujours très
marquée par votre enfance on va en
parler mais vous avez surtout dans
l'oeil
ça c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
vous avez toujours c'est ce regard
d'enfant c'est très malin très pétillant
comme ça et c'est donc je ne dis pas
votre âge mais vous êtes bien conservé
alors vous avez été quand je dis très
marquée par l'enfance vous gardez
toujours un souvenir ému par exemple de
cet appartement et beaucoup de choses
comme ça qu'ils ont marqué dans le temps
cet appartement boulevard saint michel
au 95 vous avez vécu de 1935 jusqu'à
1959 c'est à dire de de la mort de votre
père à votre à votre mariage
mais c'est ma vie s'est passé boulevard
saint michel jusqu'à mon mariage jouer
et de ce boulevard saint-michel je garde
un souvenir c'est là que j'ai eu envie
de faire du théâtre
ouais parce qu'il y avait la ligne du 38
l'autobus alors j'ai été employé de
banque à la société
c'est géant ensuite j'ai été chez
charles dullin au théâtre sarah
bernhardt ensuite ma première monte
premier théâtre le théâtre de la
renaissance où j'ai joué toute votre vie
se jouer sur 38 sur le 38 et calais gare
à la gare de l'est parce que je suis
alsacien et je rentrais chez moi
ouais et vacances alors toute ma vie
j'ai l'arête c'était mon arêtes de
poisson voilà c'était dingue alors vous
parlez souvent de votre mère marguerite
vous à vous souvenez du bruit des
aiguilles à tricoter dans le grand
appartement france ans il ya on sent que
ça vous a profondément profondément
marqué et une époque dont vous parlez
moi peut-être parce que vous avez un peu
honte de de sarran honte
encore faut-il en avoir honte mais c'est
vrai que pendant la guerre contrairement
à beaucoup de gens vous avez eu une
voulait traverser la guerre
vous avez une dizaine d'années vous
allez traverser la guerre d'une façon
quand même
privilégiez-vous et il ya neuf le vieux
dans une pension une pension qui
ressemble à un peu aux disparus de
saint-agil d'ailleurs d'après d'après ce
que j'en ai lu mais la guerre la guerre
était quand on a dix ans la guerre est
simplement il y avait mon frère qui se
battaient à cassino ouais bon alors
j'avais je me sentais des douanes et du
côté de la guerre moi disant qu'est-ce
que vous voulez que je fasse d'autre que
d'aller faire la queue au lait pour ma
mère pendant que ma mère faisait la
queue chez les pressiers moi je faisais
et puis c'était ça vous avez vécu ça
comme ça dans l'exaltation un peu des
héros de l'époque c'est-à-dire mermoz
dans votre agenda les soeurs enfin on a
parlé de mahmoud hier avec votre ami
claude brasseur saint-exupéry le père de
foucauld espèce d'exaltation et puis
vous alliez en vélo comme ça à trappes
prendre des cours chez une jolie jeune
fille ils apprennent encore mais vous
savez tout de même nom mais si je trouve
que c'est effectivement alors par
rapport à ce que d'autres personnes en
ont souffert c'est clair mais bon c'est
vrai que vous aviez dix ans et surtout
bouscule tier des marionnettes et vous
faisiez des pièces de théâtre c'est
comme ça que j'ai appris à aimer le
théâtre dans cette école du gai savoir
qui se trouvait à dos la voie qu'il se
trouvait à neauphle-le-vieux est la
nôtre presse notre professeur nous
avaient acheté des boules en bois et
avec des gauches comme ça on en avait
formé des marionnettes sont les peignait
et avec un derrière un paravent j'ai
commencé à jouer la comédie en faisant
tous les personnages et en imitant
bourvil or après la guerre évidemment là
c'est retombé je dirais un peu sur terre
quoi c'est l'après guerre
c'est kafka c'est céline et pour en
parlant de kafka vous travaillez dans
une banque pour quelqu'un comme vous
savez c'était ben j'avais envie d'en
sortir c'était au moins ça a été le coup
de fouet qui m'a rien qui m'a donné
envie de faire quelque chose dont venir
ce que ce que vous vouliez être enfin
j'adore j'ai voulu être acteur donc j'ai
réveillé ma mère à une nuit comme ça et
je lui ai dit j'ai appris qu'il y avait
d'un cours qui s'ouvrait qui étaient les
cours gratuits le déjeuner gratuit une
bourse c'était le centre du spectacle -
qui était une école d'état et je suis
arrivé dans cette école et j'ai été reçu
donc il fallait que du jour au lendemain
je quitte la banque
alors voilà ma maman membre s'est levé
et m'a dit à 2 heures du matin j'ai tout
de suite eu faire un vrai un mot pour le
directeur de la banque mais c'est vrai
qu'un soir c'est arrivé un jour c'est
arrivé en dés
vous cacher les yeux de votre mère en
disant devine qui sait c'est gérard
philipe débris en tous les soirs je
vraiment couché dans le salon et alors
je traversais le salon toujours
et puis tous les soirs je disais elle ne
faisait qu est-ce que c'est qu'est ce
que c'est c'est alors un soir où je suis
passé avec bruno cremer est qu'ils
allaient quitter au conservatoire avec
moi qui allait dormir là dans ma chambre
est alors moment indiquait ce que c'est
qu'est ce que c'est et j'ai dit si
gérard philippe et bruno cremer est
tellement qu'il a lâché le leak est
tombé sur la petite commode bouilloire
enfin c'est tabou alors selon vous
parlez de kremer vous êtes retrouvés au
conservatoire comme avec belmondo
girardot marielle rochefort enfin c'est
quand même une génération assez assez
exceptionnelle il faut bien le dire
alors après bon on va pas tous vos films
j'ai cité les principaux va ce qui en
tous les cas moi dont qui m'ont marqué
les grandes manoeuvres le caporal
épinglé l'ours en peluche avec bardot je
t'aime je t'aime de rennais en saas est
sorti dans 68 donc ce n'est pas de pot
ça tout le monde avait dit à reynet vous
allez avoir le prix de grand prix ouais
on est arrivé à cannes et on nous a
annoncé juste en arrivant que le
festival était arrêté oui la fois que
jamais ressortir en fait on alors là non
il le fait mais n'a jamais été heureux
on a jamais revus
vous n'êtes que paris première avoir la
bonne idée de le ressortir en tous les
cas le message est passé nous est
tournée après stavisky toujours toujours
avec rennais est alors en fait vous
aimez on parlait de ça hier en parler de
vous avec brasseur vous aimait par
dessus tout le théâtre et c'est vrai que
ça vous a un peu coûter votre carrière
au cinéma même si vous avez des films
complexité sont pas sont pas nuls loin
de là mais je vois là j'ai passé ma vie
j'ai passé ma vie au théâtre c'est sûr
et j étais très heureux mais arrive un
moment après le souper
j'ai eu envie de me reposer un petit peu
et puis j'ai commencé à faire un peu de
cinéma
c'est ce même film oui j'ai pu c'est
dingue c'est ça sur le jour où vous
décidez de faire du cinéma là après le
souper vous en faites vous serez en fait
quand même
mais ce qui est très étonnant d'ailleurs
si vous avez eu un césar pour une pièce
filmée en fait c'est à dire si vous avez
deux césar pour le film de molinaro da
sur le souper de brésil on avait joué
six ans fois au théâtre claude et puis
on a fait le filmer
voilà échec c'est très bien parce que
comme ça tout le monde peut profiter
même ce qu'il n'avait pas vue peuvent
profiter de cette pièce qui a très envie
c'est assez bien tourner parce que c'est
pas du théâtre filmé molinaro a fait ça
d'une façon ferme il faut dire aux gens
que la cassette est en vente étaient
alors au théâtre du château en suède il
y en a eu un aussi cliquer moi à
l'époque m'avait marqué c'était victor
où les enfants du pouvoir de vitrail qui
n'était plus belles pièces que j'ai fait
un bruit c'est à marquer ça a marqué
votre carrière ça a marqué les gens
pillent on est toujours dans le monde de
l'enfance tout alter pied prêtiez pardon
à un personnage qui a neuf ans pendant
la pièce j'ai 9 ans j'ai un père une
mère une bonne j'ai un avis récent ce
qui paraît revient à son point de départ
après martyrs et aux classes et parker
encore vous avez écrit aussi mais j'ai
écrit trois pièces oui vous avez écrit
trois pierres alors qu'ils ont plutôt
été bien accueillie à la une quand même
il y avait il eu 110 kg j'ai beaucoup
joué pintor et gilles 110 avait dit
d'une pièce et puis laquelle cdu c'est
du pin teurs gentil scénographie
oui je me souviens pas parce que j'en ai
eu des beaucoup plus méchant que ça
avant qu'ils ne soient pas mais sinon
j'ai fait une pièce qui a très bien
marché qui s'appelle un habit pour
l'hiver que nous avons joué avec piéplu
et wilson et deux nuls en leuzois
redémarre à dire un habit pour la
chambre sur la dordogne ma chambre sur
la dordogne c'est bon alors en fait vous
dit qu'on aurait toujours est-il
histoires d'enfants dit je ne me suis
jamais vraiment remis de mon enfance et
est peut-être le fait d'être acteur
c'est assez complexe depuis qu'à
repenser surnom vous pensez pas c'est à
dire que l'époque de l'enfance et une
époque où tout est permis l'époque où on
a envie de tout tout et est ouvert où
l'amour l'envi 2
de réussir l'on vit à partir d'un
certain moment eh bien je sais pas que
je suis pas déçu de la vue du tout au
contraire vous n'êtes pas de quoi non
mais c'est plus j'essaie de retrouver
l'enfance pour retrouver mon
enthousiasme à marquer quand vous jouez
avec valérie lemercier le rôle que vous
jouez c'est un plaisir de s'amuser
c'est vraiment une preuve j pas d'un
centimètre méforme et d'enfants santé
parce que franchement un laurier cette
maison aussi que vous avez vous avez
créé enfin complètement je vous l'avais
acheté c'était et quatre murs au milieu
d'un champ et vous avez recréer
complètement cette maison pour retrouver
une ambiance d'enfance parce que avant
le boulevard saint-michel vous étiez
dans une maison c'est ça non plus parce
que j'ai toujours je suis un homme du
19e à peu j'ai toujours rêvé d'une
maison qui aurait été là au début du 19e
siècle les mains j'ai créé une maison
comme ça dans un creux de vallon près de
paris vers il n y avait hors jeu valve
alors vous avez acheté cette maison que
vous êtes ruiner pour cette maison non
parce qu'elle a grandi cinq six fois de
suite
oui c'est ma danse vgg j'ai été du jeu
dès que je trouvais avec un crochet
j'allais dans les démolitions je
remercie les vieilles tôt m viel payer
maintenant il ya même un seul qui
appartenait à pierre richard vivre ça je
sais pas qui se souvient david charvet
aujourd'hui maman maman était son thé
c'était son acteur préféré le jeune
premier le grand jeune première bien
entendu est-ce que c'est pas aussi ce
côté enfantin est ce que c'est pas dû
aussi au fait que vous avez la foi si
vous avez vous dit volontiers je suis
comme ma mère j'ai la foi du charbonnier
ses traits enfantins sans mémoire comme
ça sans réfléchir non c'est à dire que
c'est peut-être plus facile que en
réfléchissant
ouais ça vous non ça m'aide beaucoup et
je dire que je crois en dieu alors je le
dis et c'est ma façon de d'être chrétien
si vous voulez c'est bien l'écouter je
vous remercie a tout fait plaisir à voir
un franchement je rappelle le titre du
film donc on ne parle que de ça toute
façon ce moment à paris et j'espère en
france bientôt se mêlent le derrière de
valérie lemercier et ça vaut le
déplacement
merci beaucoup et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de l'inédit tube abonnez vous
il m'était impossible